from the whitehouse.gov blueprint for an
AI Bill of Rights making automated
systems work for the American people
excellent I think it's a lot of nothing
to be honest I was I was looking at it
just for a little bit and uh let's just
talk about what their what their uh
proposal is today and this was released
today the same day Elon
um came out and said he's gonna buy
that's right safe and effective systems
algorithmic discrimination protections
data privacy notice and explanation
human Alternatives consideration and
fallback now I don't know these are kind
of like nebulous terms but some of it's
actually I agree with safe and effective
systems automated systems should it be
developed with consultation from diverse
communities stakeholders take a look at
that what does that word mean Luke
what stakeholder stakeholders you know
people who have stakes and they eat them
and they hold they're holding the stuff
people love skin in the game I'm gonna
give you one more chance Luke now you
don't know go ahead of the people who of
course are are it's the world yes
investors controllers centralizers new
new it's their no it means you the
Warlock in mcforum says we have to move
Beyond shareholders and move towards
stakeholder economy which is who is it
who is affected by this as opposed to
who owns it so this is basically World
economic Forum Davos type language and
um you know yeah language is a domain
experts identify concerns risk potential
impacts in the systems blah blah blah
blah blah look I I agree you know Ian's
brought this up if you don't know what
an algorithm is doing to you like when
Facebook was experimenting on people we
got a problem and they should be allowed
to do that the next one's actually
really interesting algorithmic
discrimination protections they say you
should not face discrimination by
algorithms and systems should be used
and designed in an equitable way oh here
we go Equitable exciting but here's the
interesting thing they say you can't be
discriminated on the basis of race color
ethnicity sex pregnancy childbirth
medical conditions and identity intersex
status religion age national origin
disability veteran status genetic
information or any other classification
protected by law full stop that's a very
very Broad and bold thing to say what
does that mean protected by law there's
a bunch of different places in this
country that have different parameters
for the human rights law notably
Washington DC which says political
affiliation is a protected class right
if they're going to claim anything
protected by law well then all certain
DC it is does that mean if they were to
implement these policies if you live in
DC could you sue if you were banned for
political reasons um that's interesting
thing is that a States right thing
didn't DeSantis do something like that
in Florida where uh if you are running
for office and you get banned you can
sue I can't remember exactly what it was
he did something like that on a state
level
yeah the thing is though the defense
will just be well we banned them for
something else right instead of
political reasons but then even if it's
it's not working because as we saw with
Alex Berenson when he sued I guess the
ruling was they have to explain what
they did because you have a contract
with them so like
you know I can put in a contract I have
I can terminate this contract for these
specific reasons what Twitter does
Twitter says we can ban you for these
reasons and so if they ban you and it's
for a reason they have to explain
exactly what they did I suppose there's
an argument that they say we can ban you
for any reason or no reason but there
was a new I think it was a fifth Circuit
Court ruling where the judge said no
they can't these big platforms can't
just ban you arbitrarily they don't have
the right to do that so that'll be
interesting to see how that gets
adjudicated as it makes it the Supreme
Court
because that's not actually a contract
if they could do that I mean wouldn't
that be some sort of violation what am I
thinking would it be some sort of
violation if they can just change their
rules and ban you as they go and change
the rules if you if you get on Twitter
in 2010 and then they've changed the
rules change the rules change the rules
like are you agreeing to all those
changes this is a big thing with patreon
there was like there was a lawsuit and
patreon abruptly changed their rules and
tried to get everyone to agree to the
new rules without because they don't
know what it is and it was because it
was gonna the the suit required them to
go to arbitration and they had to pay
the cost of arbitration so if like a
million people Sue they gotta pay you
know 100 million dollars for some
ridiculous amount so they tried changing
the rules and the judge was like when
these people signed up
they sign up and agreed under these
terms and the action you took which
violated the terms happened before you
changed the contract so we are going to
operate under the previous rules I don't
know where that case ended up going but
this is interesting because
I believe big Tech platforms should not
have the right to just ban you for no
reason that should be stricken as just
like not applicable oh and so the the
example I'll give you is we need to
treat we need to start treating this all
like like being a tenant a landlord or
like you're the big Tech platforms are
landlords renting you space in exchange
for something in this case for Twitter
it's by you being in the platform they
can sell advertisements so there's a net
there's an exchange good there's an
exchange here
imagine a landlord was like you can live
in this building the rent is 2500 bucks
a month and you're like okay now here's
the reasons I can evict you if you smash
the windows if you're throwing food out
the window if you're too noisy and you
won't stop and also for literally any
reason at any time
yeah no no court is gonna pull that
they're back you can't do that there's
laws so I view this stuff like no no no
Twitter YouTube Facebook they don't get
to say we're going to enter in to a
monetization contract where you can
start a business you can monetize the
pla monetize yourself on this platform
we are going to monetize you but we can
terminate the contract at any reason
with with no no I think imagine if the
world operated this way like you go to a
landlord in in downtown of your city and
you're like I'm gonna open a bakery and
they say okay so long as you're not
making like swastika cupcakes I don't
care you're fine and then one day for no
reason he says you know you uh you know
you made mint chocolate chip cupcakes
and I hate it so I'm kicking you out I
don't got to give you a reason how could
businesses survive if landlords could
just terminate a business like that with
no argument with no with no lawsuit
now that most businesses are moving
online now that tons of people make
their living on the internet we
absolutely have to today ensure
protections for people as if they're a
tenant I agree with that because I went
through it
um right after the uh right after not
after the election but after the
um when Biden got into office January
21st I ended up getting banned from
Twitter and I was never told why I was
just banned arbitrarily banned and I was
gone until
uh the last week in April this year when
Elon said he was going to buy Twitter
and I miraculously reappeared
um and but that was a really tough
because you know I had like kind of
built this brand and I I was you know
like growing and I was spreading a
message and I was just gone one day and
I I was no longer in the Public Square
and no I didn't do anything wrong and
did they give you a message or no just
like you you violated terms and you can
appeal this so I appealed it and then
they were like you know three months
later they're like no no now you're now
you're permanently suspended and I'm
like
that's what you get for appealing I know
right like yeah so so it was just it was
it was really difficult you know to be
kicked out of the Public Square I mean
I'm just I I don't post anything that
bad I don't think but
um yeah so I've lived through it I am
absolutely an advocate for
an AI Bill of Rights you know I know why
they're doing about this one now now I
don't know about this one I haven't read
through the whole thing yet but this one
I mean the timing of it with who gets to
make enforce this AI Bill of Rights and
a lot of the language is very broad you
know so so I would have to take a closer
look at it but there are points that I
do agree with in there like the Arbiter
Banning of why whatever you know but but
of course that's not going to be in
there and you should never trust the
government oh God and you should never
trust the government ever if they use
broad generalized language because they
will use it for their own personal
interest and they have been manipulating
social media for their own personal
benefit already in such an extensive
bastardized way that it's sickening to
most people yeah I agree with this one
right here human Alternatives it says
you should be able to opt out where
appropriate and have access to a person
who can quickly consider and remedy
problems you encounter that would grow
jobs too because nobody works at Twitter
exactly it's just too big yeah but my my
response would that be a regulation to
force Twitter to have a bunch of human
customer service agents yeah is that
what that is and considering their
profits are in the billions they can
afford to hire a lot of customer service
agents
though but but what they usually do is
they they Outsource it they go to places
like Africa they go to places in Asia
and they get cheap labor markets to do a
lot of the Banning and censoring and
there was even a controversy with one
big Tech social media company hiring a
specific group of people that that hated
uh people for their uh you know
sexuality and they they went on a purge
Banning people and there was no way to
get any justice from it because there's
no way of contacting Google and being
like hey uh why did I get banned can I
talk to somebody can I please have some
kind of way to have some accountability
here none of that I'm just I'm just
concerned that this only uh helps
Twitter keep their market share in the
big providers uh it could be a barrier
to entry requiring additional costs to
enter
the market and start up a new social
media platform I mean it is it is it is
it is a problem that you have companies
that say we're not I mean look if if you
start a company that people are signing
up for and then they have encounter a
problem that breaches the contract and
you say I'm not going to remedy that
then they sue you and I suppose the
issue is poor people can't afford to sue
so what companies just get away with
screwing over customers you like imagine
if this is a brick and mortar store and
you and customers came in and said how
do I return this product it was
defective you say we actually don't have
any customer service you can email us I
mean that's that's not okay so maybe
it's going to bake costs into things but
there you you need to be able to remedy
your problems with it with a human being
and I think I don't know about Twitter
because Twitter is garbage and there's
too many people on it one of the issues
is that the value of an individual is
not great enough to Warrant the cost of
a customer service rep this is one of
the problems with the massive user base
of these platforms and also of you know
governance in the United States 770 000
people per congressional district you
can't even and address all the issues of
every single person you get someone on
Facebook
and they're I think I think a Twitter
user's value is like two dollars and so
how many Twitter users do you need to
cover the cost per year of one employee
so that is that employee able to
actually address all of the concerns and
issues that's not not going to happen I
do think one of the biggest problems
with all these platforms is that they
keep catering to these whiny babies now
let's do another brick and mortar you
know uh analogy imagine you own a
cupcake shop and there's a dude sitting
there talking with his buddies minding
his own business in the corner and he's
talking about how he voted for Donald
Trump so some other guy on the other
side gets up and says kick him out now
Karen and yeah and they're like why
because he is saying hateful things
Donald Trump is a racist and they're
like okay sir you have to leave because
you've upset this person he's like what
what did I do like well you were saying
things that upset him so get out how are
you supposed to function as a business
like that it should be the other way
around if you've got a problem you can
leave here's your cupcake bye-bye
there's the door this dude's minding his
own business system is it's I just don't
see how this works granted I think the
White House AI stuff is some people are
matching in the chat they're trying to
save themselves because they know Elon
is going to come in and take control of
the narrative exactly that's why the
timing I was like soon as I saw that why
did they shot the Chaser exactly well he
also talked about opening up the
algorithm so it allows people to see
what they're actually subscribed to a
crazy idea as of course we are ruled by
algorithms that that not only control
what we see but also sensor content
arbitrarily not on Fair rules as we
learned recently there's a certain rules
for very famous people and there's a
certain rule for people who don't have
as many followers people who don't have
as much influence who of course get
punished more this was specifically uh
detailed with Facebook who of course get
to play by different set of rules so
that's a completely unfair system it's
not just there's no clear rules and I
think they want no rules so you have to
live in fear so you have to think twice
before you post anything so you have to
worry hey will I lose my ability to to
have a voice in our conversation in in
in in the National dialogue if I if I
dare talk about this idea This Is How
They Roll they rule through fear and
censorship which is absolutely a
disgusting abuse of power they want
there to be no rules no uh well Elon
Musk specifically talked about opening
up the the source code and the algorithm
where people get to see what they're
subscribed to see he also talked about
rules especially when it comes to adult
content especially when it comes to
Illegal content that is already illegal
in the United States and punishable uh
with you know a law enforcement stepping
in and punishing people for saying and
doing certain things so obviously there
are some rules here but when it comes to
an algorithm where you see exactly what
you're subscribed to see I think that's
a that's an amazing thing that made the
internet so popular in the first place I
wonder aside from the fact that um a lot
of the
um people with the larger followings are
protected I wonder if that also has to
do with ads they're going to sell more
ads because these people have or there's
going to get more viewership to the ads
on the accounts of uh the larger
followings
I think they do a cost benefit analysis
and they say
if we ban ex-people
how many followers will leave for those
people being banned and then how much
revenue do we lose and they ultimately
determine you know what the left is more
cantankerous than the right if we ban
someone on the left they get really
really mad and they lose their minds and
then they threaten boycotts and they
organize boycotts the right doesn't they
won't even take off work to go protest
the left will so the the the the the
cost benefit analysis is simple you ban
someone on the right you're going to
lose money but you'll lose more money if
you don't Pander to the left
so that's what they do although
surprisingly because I'd imagine a lot
of people on the left don't have a lot
of money but I guess it's skus it's like
on the right you have more working
people more middle class people on the
left you have wealthier people so it's
like
we only need to keep a hundred thousand
wealthy Democrats happy on Twitter but
we have to keep a million Republicans
happy to to get the same level of you
know you know buying purchasing power so
it's just it's obvious which which
direction this goes thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there